.
WELCOME TO TIMPF!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Kat: BEEN ABOUT A MONTH SINCE
I HOSTED LAST TIME AND THE
REVIEWS WERE AMAZING.
I COULDN'T EVEN WALK DOWN THE
STREET WITHOUT BEING ACCOSTED BY
THE FANS.
OKAY, THEY WERE VAGRANTS WHO
LIVE UNDER THE BRIDGE NEAR MY
APARTMENT.
BUT THAT REMINDS ME THAT WE
SHOULD TALK ABOUT FENTANYL.
FIRST OF ALL, YES, IT IS THE
REASON THAT GREG IS OUT.
I PROMISED HIM I WOULDN'T SAY
ANYTHING BUT I FEEL LIKE IT'S
FINE TO LIE TO YOUR BOSS WHO
ACCUSES YOU OF DOING DRUGS EVERY
DAY.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT WHY FENTANYL IS A HUGE
PROBLEM AND WHY THE GOVERNMENT
CAN'T BE THE ONE TO SOLVE IT.
LATELY THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
TALK ABOUT CLASSIFYING FENTANYL
AS A WEAPON OF MASS DESTRUCTION
OR DRUG CARTELS AS TERRORIST
ORGANIZATIONS OR ANY SALE OF
FENTANYL RESULTING IN A FATAL
OVERDOSE AS A FEDERAL CRIME
WORTHY OF THE DEATH PENALTY.
BUT LIKE THAT LORD OF THE RINGS
PREQUEL SHOW, ALL OF IT IS A BAD
IDEA.
DON'T AT ME IN OTHER WORDS, EVEN
YOU KNOW IT'S [BLEEP].
IT'S NOT THAT I THINK FENTANYL
POISONING IS NOT A THREAT AND I
DO SAY POISONING BECAUSE MANY OF
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE DIED FROM
FENTANYL DIDN'T INTEND TO TAP
FENTANYL AT ALL.
IT'S NOT LIKE PEOPLE ARE
TOASTING WITH IT AT WEDDINGS OR
SERVING IT.
A 2015 STUDY IN THE HARM
REDUCTION JOURNAL FOUND THAT 73%
OF HEROIN USERS WHO TESTED
POSITIVE FOR FENTANYL DIDN'T
EVEN KNOW THEY HAD BEEN USING
FENTANYL.
IT'S NOT JUST HEROIN USERS.
BEEN FOUND IN EVERYTHING FROM
PILLS, COCAINE TO MDMA.
FENTANYL POISONINGS ARE A
SERIOUS WIDESPREAD PROBLEM BUT
JUST BECAUSE THE GOVERNMENT
PASSES SOME LAW, THAT DOESN'T
MEAN IT'S GOING TO HELP.
EVEN IF THEY GIVE IT A MAGICAL
NAME LIKE THE
NO-MORE-FENTANYL-EVER BILL.
OR THE INFLATION REDUCTION ACT.
LET'S GO BRANDON, AM I RIGHT!
WOO.
NOTHING TO DO WITH ANYTHING I'M
TALKING ABOUT I JUST WANTED
EVERYONE TO CLAP FOR ME.
THANK YOU, I NEEDED THAT.
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH.
OKAY.
ANYWAY, THE CDC'S 2016
GUIDELINES THAT WERE CRACKING
DOWN ON OPEN 88 PRESCRIPTIONS
WERE DISASTROUS.
A STUDY FOUND PATIENTS WHO
ABRUPTLY STOPPED OPEN 88
PRESCRIPTIONS WERE PRONE TO
SUICIDE.
THE CDC LOOSENING GUIDELINES
WHICH IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION, A STEP PEOPLE WITH
CHRONIC PAIN CAN ONLY TAKE, BY
THE WAY, IF THEY HAVE THEIR PRE
JINX.
RESTRICTING OPEN 88 PRE
VEHICLESES HASN'T EVEN REDUCED
OPIOID DEATHS.
ACTUALLY IT'S MADE IT WORSE, AS
OPIAT PRESCRIPTIONS HAVE FALLEN
SO CALLED OVERDOSE FATALITIES
HAVE GONE UP AND, MUCH LIKE
GREG'S FOREHEAD, IT KEEPS
GETTING HIGHER.
THE CONSISTENT TREND, WE SAW IT
IN 2019, WE SAW IT IN 2020, AND
THEN LAST YEAR THE DEATHS
REACHED AN ALL-TIME HIGH OF MORE
THAN A HUNDRED THOUSAND.
I THINK THAT EVERY ADULT SHOULD
HAVE THE RIGHT TO PUT WHATEVER
THEY WANT INTO THEIR OWN BODY
WITHOUT RISKING GOING TO PRISON
FOR IT.
WHETHER IT'S TAKING DRUGS OR,
WORSE, EATING NOTHING BUT LONG
JOHN SILVERS.
AND I KNOW PEOPLE SAY, WHAT
ABOUT THE CHILDREN.
BUT PROHIBITION IS ALSO HAVING
DEADLY CONSEQUENCES FOR MINORS,
TOO.
JOE FRIEDMAN A UCLA RESEARCHERS
SAYS WHILE THE NUMBER OF FATAL
OVERDOSES AMONG AD LENSES
DOUBLED FROM 2019 TO 2020 SAYS
QUOTE IT APPEARS THE RISE IN
DEATH WAS FUELED NOT BY GREATER
NUMBER OF TEENS USING DRUGS,
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ACTUALLY WENT
DOWN BY THE PANDEMIC BUT BY USE
OF DANGEROUS AND HIGHLY POTENT
FORMS OF FENTANYL AND AS
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF DRUG ABUSE
DIRECTOR DR. NORAH POINTS OUT,
TEENS ARE NOT TRYING TO DO
FENTANYL ON PURPOSE, IT'S JUST
THAT NOW IT'S SO COMMON FOR ANY
DRUG TO BE POISONED WITH IT.
PLUS NOT LIKE DRUGS BEING
ILLEGAL IS THE ONLY REASON MOST
PEOPLE DECIDE TO STAY AWAY WITH
THEM.
I DON'T DO HEROIN OR CRACK
REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD FROM GREG.
>> GUN STORE SHELVES ARE NOW AS
EMPTY AS KAT'S MEDICINE CABINET
AFTER A LONG WEEKEND OR IF
YOU'RE IN BETWEEN PIPES ON YOUR
CRACK PIPE KAT.
KAT DOES DRUGS AND SHE STILL HAS
A JOB.
>> Kat: OH, MISS THAT GUY.
I DON'T THE DO DRUGS AND THE
REASON I DON'T ISN'T CAUSE IT'S
ILLEGAL OR 'CAUSE IT'S HARD TO
GET.
FINDING CRACK IN NEW YORK CITY
IS EASIER THAN FINDING SHAQ IN A
CROWD OF KINDERGARTNERS.
IT'S BECAUSE I KNOW I WOULD
PROBABLY LOVE DRUGS.
I WOULD GET A DINGED TO DRUGS.
AND I HAVEN'T REALLY SEEN IT
WORK OUT TOO WELL FOR ANYONE
WHEN IT HAPPENS.
THE BEST CASE SCENARIO PROBABLY
IS HUNTER BIDEN AND MY DAD IS
SLIGHTLY LESS INFLUENTIAL THAN
HIS DAD IS.
YOU ALSO DON'T HAVE TO AGREE
WITH ME ON COMPLETE LEGALIZATION
TO REALIZE WHY THE PLAN TO
DESIGNATE CARTELS OR DRUG
DEALERS AS TERRORISTS IS A
REALLY BAD IDEA.
DESIGNATING A NEW TERRORIST
GROUP WOULD JUST GIVE THE
GOVERNMENT MORE EXPANDED
SURVEILLANCE POWERS, MORE EXCUSE
TOSS VIOLATE CIVIL LIBERTIES.
ANY PAYING ATTENTION KNOWS THAT
WOULD DEFINITELY BE ABUSE.
JUST LIKE HOW THE PATRIOT ACT
WAS PUT IN PLACE WITH THE
PROMISE OF PROTECTING US OF
ANOTHER 9/11 BUT WOUND UP
VIOLATING RIGHTS TO EVERYONE
FROM MUSLIM AMERICANS TO MOORNTS
CRITICIZE THEIR SCHOOL BOARDS.
PLUS THE MORE THE GOVERNMENT
TRIES TO CRACK DOWN ON SMUGGLING
THE MORE YOU ACTUALLY PUSH THE
BLACK MARKET TOWARDS FENTANYL
BECAUSE ITS POTENCY MAKES IT
EASIER TO SMUGGLE BECAUSE YOU
NEED SMALLER AMOUNTS AND IT'S
CHEAPER TO PRODUCE THAN HEROIN.
THE BLACK MARKET IS GOING TO
LOOK OUT FOR ITSELF.
IT'S GOING TO DO THE THINGS THAT
MAKE THE MOST SENSE FOR ITS
BUSINESS MODEL, AND ITS BUSINESS
MODEL HAS BEEN REALLY
SUCCESSFUL.
FAR MORE SO THAN MARY KAY.
THE MAKEUP COMPANY, NOT MY
FRIEND MARY KAY, WHO DOES SELL
HEROIN.
AND WHO IS ACTUALLY FAR LESS
ANNOYING THAN ANYONE WHO DOES
SELL MARY KAY.
LOOK I KNOW I MIGHT SOUND CRAZY
TO SOME OF YOU BUT HONESTLY
NOTHING CAN BE AS CRAZY AS
CONTINUING TO DO THE SAME THING
AND RESPOND TO A FAILED WAR ON
DRUGS BY INTENSIFYING IT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> PERIOD!
>> Kat: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
SHE TALKS SO FAST I THINK SHE'S
READING THE SIDE EFFECTS TO
ADDERALL.
EMILY COMPAGNO!
HE KNOWS SO MUCH ABOUT THE
ECONOMY HE MIGHT BE A LOOM
NATTY.
HOST OF FOX NEWS BUSINESS, LARRY
KUDLOW!
>> HE LOOKS LIKE A COMEDIAN
WHICH IS NOT REALLY A
COMPLIMENT, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
TOM SHILLUE.
NOBODY COULD EVER BE IN THE SAME
BOAT AS HIM, HE'S A GUY.
THE NWA WORLD TELEVISION
CHAMPION TYRUS!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Kat: YAY.
I DON'T KNOW, EVERYTHING'S FINE.
SO EMILY, I BET YOU CAME
PREPARED WITH LIKE NO
STATISTICS.
>> Emily: NONE AT ALL.
>> Kat: THAT YOU'VE BEEN WORKING
TO MEMORIZE AND WANT TO RATTLE
OFF AT ME RIGHT NOW.
>> Emily: I WILL SAY THIS.
THAT I LOVED ALL THE POINTS YOU
MADE IN YOUR MONOLOGUE BUT I
THINK GOVERNOR ABBOTT TRYING TO
DESIGNATE OR ACTUALLY
DESIGNATING THE TERRORIST GROUP
OR THE CARTELS AS TERRORIST
GROUPS I THINK SPEAKS TO THE
DESPERATION.
TO ME IT SPEAKS TO THE GOVERNOR
WHO FEELS HIS PRESIDENT HAS AND
INDICATED HAD IS ENTIRE DUTY TO
SAFEGUARDS ALL OF THE US AND ALL
OF YOUR STATS ARE HORRIFYING.
THE FACT THAT TEEN-AGERS RIGHT
NOW ARE ENCOUNTERING ONE OF
EVERY THREE COUNTERFEIT PILLS
BEING LACED WITH FENTANYL MEANS
IF THEY ARE DABBLING AT A PARTY,
IF THEY WANT TO TAKE
RECREATIONAL USE OF OPIATES I'M
NOT CONDONING IT BUT THE RISK OF
DEATH ARE MULTIPLIED BY
MILLIONS.
GOVERNOR ABBOTT POINTED OUT IN
PART OF HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER MORE
AMERICANS HAVE DIED THIS YEAR
ALONE THAN EVERY GLOBAL
TERRORIST ATTACK IN THE LAST
HUNDRED YEARS.
WE ARE CRYING OUT FOR HELP AND
OUR GOVERNMENT AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL IS DOING NOTHING.
SO HIM TRYING TO DESIGNATE THEM
AS TERRORIST ORGANIZATIONS TO ME
JUST SCREAMS OUT, MAN, I NEED
HELP BECAUSE MY PRESIDENT AND
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS DOING
NOTHING TO STYMIE THE CARTELS
AND CHINA FROM POISONING
AMERICANS ESPECIALLY OUR YOUTH
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Kat: AND, LOOK, OF COURSE
THAT IS -- THAT'S A WELL
INTENTIONED THING, RIGHT?
AND A LOT OF THESE ARE WELL
INTENTIONED.
I'M JUST A PERSON WHO SAYS I SEE
HOW THIS CAN BE ABUSED AND I
HAVE TO WAIT EIGHT TO 13 YEARS
AND PEOPLE TELL ME I WAS RIGHT.
A LOT OF IT'S WELL INTENTIONED,
TOM.
LIKE, WANTING TO, FOR EXAMPLE,
PUT THE DEATH PENALTY FOR DRUG
DEALERS, UNTIL YOU REALIZE THAT,
YOU KNOW, ANYONE CONNECTED TO
MAYBE AN OVERDOSE MAY BE LESS
LIKELY TO GO GET HELP BECAUSE
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT GOING TO
JAIL THEMSELVES.
SO GOOD INTENTIONS DOESN'T
ALWAYS MAKE A GOOD LAW.
>> Larry: I THINK THAT'S TRUE
KAT.
WAY TO DO A NUANCED AND COMPLEX
STORY IN THE A BLOCK.
>> Kat: YEAH!
GREG DOESN'T TAKE THAT MANY DAYS
OFF.
>> Larry: GREG USUALLY THROWS
SAY SOFT ONE OVER THE PLATE IN
THE A BLOCK LIKE INFLATION GOOD
OR BAD.
>> Kat: NO, I TALK ABOUT DRUGS
AND KIDS.
>> Larry: I'LL SIMPLIFY IT.
FENTANYL IS BAD, NO GOOD, RIGHT?
>> Kat: YES.
>> Larry: BUT I AGREE THAT THIS
GESTURE FROM GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTT IS NOT GOING TO DO
ANYTHING.
IF YOU READ THE STORIES IT SAYS
HE HAS DECLARED DRUG CARTELS TO
BE TERRORISTS AND YOU READ THE
STORY AND YOU SAY, WELL, WHAT
DOES THAT DO?
REALLY, PRACTICALLY WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THAT HAPPENS?
NOTHING HAPPENS.
>> Emily: IT ENABLES THEM TO
CRIMINALLY PROSECUTE UNDER
CERTAIN FEDERAL LAWS
>> Tom: FEDERAL LAWS.
>> Emily: AND UNDER A LARGER
GREATER RESOURCES PUTS MORE
TOOLS IN HIS TOOLBOX.
>> Kat: AND MORE POTENTIAL FOR
SURVEILLANCE FROM THE IF HE
SAID.
>> Emily: BUT HIM SURVEILLANCE
VERSUS DEATH.
>> Kat: THAT'S THE SAME THING
THEY SAID ABOUT 9/11.
>> Larry: LOOK, I APPRECIATE
YOUR LIBERTARIAN POINT OF VIEW
ON THIS, OKAY?
I GET THAT.
>> Kat: UH-HUH.
>> Larry: ON THE OTHER HAND, I
THINK YOU HAVE TO DISTINGUISH
BETWEEN SUPPLIERS AND USERS.
I THINK THAT THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
HERE IS OUR BORDER HAS BECOME
WIDE OPEN.
WE HAVE NO BORDERS, WE HAVE NO
NATIONAL SOVEREIGNTY.
JOE BIDEN HASN'T DONE A THING
ABOUT IT EXCEPT MAKE IT WORSE.
HE NEVER EVEN MENTIONS THE WORD
FENTANYL MUCH LESS DOING
ANYTHING ABOUT IT AND THERE
SHOULD BE STRICT PENALTIES FOR
SUPPLIERS AND DRUG DEALERS, IN
GENERAL BUT SPECIFICALLY WITH
FENTANYL.
THE OTHER POINT TO CONSIDER IS
WE'RE LETTING CHINA GET AWAY
WITH MURDER, LIKE WE ALWAYS DO,
OKAY.
THIS STUFF, THE RAW MATERIALS
COME FROM CHINA, PASS THROUGH
MEXICO AND THEN COME ACROSS THE
BORDER.
THE OPEN BORDER.
SO I DON'T SEE WHY WE CAN'T DO
SOMETHING.
I DON'T WANT NECESSARILY MORE
GOVERNMENT LAWS INSOFAR AS
PEOPLE WHO ARE USING IT, OKAY?
THAT'S A DEATH WARRANT AND THEY
CAN FIGURE THAT OUT FOR
THEMSELVES.
I'M REALLY GLAD THAT YOU DON'T
USE IT.
>> Kat: NOT TO BRAG.
>> Larry: I'VE BEEN, YOU KNOW,
I'VE BEEN DOWN THAT ROAD MYSELF
AND BEEN SOBER A LONG TIME
THANKFULLY, GRACEFULLY WITH
GOD'S HELP.
BUT I DO THINK THOSE WHO SELL IT
SHOULD BE IN DEEP TROUBLE,
WHETHER IT'S CAPITOL PUNISHMENT
OR SOMETHING VERY DIFFICULT AND
I DO THINK THIS PRESIDENT SHOULD
WAKE UP AND SEE WHAT THIS OPEN
BORDER AND UNLIMITED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION IS DOING TO THIS
COUNTRY.
INSOFAR AS DRUGS AND CRIME AND
SEX AND ALL THE REST OF IT.
IT IS AN ABSOLUTE NIGHTMARE AND
HE JUST STANDS THERE, OR SITS
THERE, OR DOES SOMETHING THERE,
NOTHING TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
>> Kat: I DO --
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Kat: I DO WONDER ABOUT THE
SEX PART OF THAT.
TYRUS WOULD YOU LIKE TO --.
>> Tyrus: I DID NOT WONDER ABOUT
THE SEX PART OF THAT.
EVERYONE HAS STRONG POINTS BUT
I'M JUST GOING TO BREAK IT DOWN
TO HOW I LOOK AT IT.
IF WE CHANGE THE NAME TO
FENTANYL TO ANTHRAX, EVERYONE
WOULD BE HAVING A HEART ATTACK
RIGHT NOW.
AND WHAT DOES FENTANYL DO THAT
ANTHRAX DOESN'T DO?
SAME THING.
YOU GET IT ON YOUR FINGERS IT
COULD POISE SON YOU, IN YOUR
FOOD IT CAN POISON YOU YOU
BREATHE IT IN IT CAN POISON YOU
SO IS IT A DRUG OR POISONING?
AND WE KNOW HOW IT'S GETTING IN
HERE.
I DON'T CARE WHAT YOU CALL THEM
BUT THEY'RE POISONING AMERICANS
AND THE REASON I DON'T LOOK AT
IT THE SAME WAY AS A DRUG, AS
YOU POINTED OUT IN YOUR
MONOLOGUE, NO ONE IS GOING OUT
ON A FENTANYL RUN.
SO IT IS BEING USED AS A POISON
DISGUISED TO ATTACK THE WEAKEST
PART OF SOCIETY SO IT IS A
POISEN.
AND JUST CALL IT ANTHRAX AND
IMAGINE.
WE HAD ONE ENVELOPE OF ANTHRAX
SENT TO THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE
ENTIRE WORLD STOPPED.
WE LITERALLY HAVE TONS OF
ANTHRAX BEING PUSHED THROUGH OUR
BORDER.
SO, TO ME, I LOOK AT IT LIKE AN
ACT OF WAR.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS, IT'S
AFFECTING THE LOWEST POINT OF
OUR SOCIETY, AND UNTIL,
UNFORTUNATELY, SOMEONE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE GOES THROUGH A
FENTANYL POISONING OR LOSING A
LOVED ONE, THEN MAYBE THEY'LL
LOOK AT IT FOR WHAT IT IS.
I LOOK AT IT AS A TERRORIST
ATTACK.
I DON'T PEOPLE WATCHING MY HOUSE
BUT IF THAT MEANS WE'RE GOING TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT THE POISONING
OF AMERICA THEN I'M ALL FOR IT.
BUT AGAIN CHANGE THE WORD FOR
ONE SECOND AND SEE HOW YOU LOOK
AT IT
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Kat: OF COURSE, FENTANYL WHEN
IT DOES HAVE LEGITIMATE MEDICAL
USES IN A MEDICAL SETT